[Musique]
vous êtes
un spectacle de fin d'année rêver
c'était le 26 juin dernier sur la scène
de l'auditorium
ils sont soixante dix a chanté les
élèves de trois classes de l'école paul
langevin et leurs professeurs
une grande première et un grand bonheur
pour tous
même avec le trac quand il faut parler
devant une salle comble comme michael ou
romanes oui ils disent qu'il y aura des
travaux mais on n'ira pas à l'opéra
s'est pas complètement moi j'aime bien
cirées blix mais faut pas trop se dire
pas son but et après tu peux te tromper
l'histoire que raconte ce spectacle
c'est un peu celle de ses interprètes
des élèves qui doit visiter l'opéra et
s'y retrouve à jouer les chanteurs
lyriques
après de multiples péripéties autant de
grands moments pour les enfants ce qu'on
est et acier et tout est bon format pdf
j'aime bien parce que je suis devant et
puis après on jouait à 6tu que je suis
devant
j'adore âge c'est ma chanson préférée
[Musique]
à la direction musicale guillaume lavoie
lui aussi se régale
il a préparé ce spectacle pendant des
mois avec les enfants de l'école paul
langevin moeurs enseignants et l'équipe
de l'opéra de dijon et on a été jusqu'au
bout on a eu des moments difficiles
aussi avec les enfants des moments
vraiment motivant d'autres un peu moins
et puis quand on arrive sur le plateau
on sent que voilà la pression monte la
pression monte et puis au final un
résultat qui magnifie
[Musique]
ils ont jamais chanté comme aujourd'hui
c'était vraiment je crois la meilleure
la meilleure des de toutes les
répétitions qu'on a fait jamais ils ont
donné autant d'énergie autant d'émotions
même dans les visages dans les regards
là ça y est on avait vraiment de vrais
acteurs sur scène c'était c'était son
boulot
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et si on voulait comprendre comment des
élèves qui n'étaient jamais allés à
l'opéra ont réussi à bluffer même leur
chef de choeur
il fallait attendre la fin du spectacle
la réponse était dans le dernier chant
[Musique]
une maîtresse
extra ça c'est une chose mais en
coulisses les enfants ont aussi une
autre explication
on avait beaucoup progressé et du coup
va se dire qu'on a travaillé
violetta réseau laventure musical qui
s'achève ce jour là sous les
applaudissements a duré six mois six
mois d'apprentissage et de découverte
[Applaudissements]
ouais